Wonder of the world is a theta girl
Parted the sea
When he made me
I cannot believe you're not stepping with us this year
I've got to focus on getting into Harvard
There's a video online of a sigma beta beta member having sex on their lawn.
You need to make SBB look like positive contributors to the community
Don't you have a a big charity step competition coming up?
Let's go!
I can't teach them
My black card would get revoked
You make this SBB mess go away and I will guarantee you admission to Harvard
I think I have a way to save your charter and get you reinstated
You would compete in a charity step show
I'm an excellent country line dancer
That surprises no one
Stepping requires an extraordinary amount of discipline.
We don't drink during the week
Calm down
Get your flat asses in gear!
Go! Go! Go!
My ass is perfectly shaped for my frame!
I gotta see what I'm working with
Okay! I've seen enough
You're not teaching them, are you Jam?
Girl you crazy
If my sorors find out I am teaching you to step, it is gonna get ugly
Like love and hip hop reunion show ugly
But I like love and hip hop reunion shows
I don't
White people stepping
I know
That's the dumbest shit I've ever heard
You bitch!
Are you kidding me!
If they can't work together as a team, we're screwed.
What did she trip on? Life?
The shade is real.
Nobody respects you guys because you don't respect each other
If you build up the sisterhood, I promise you have a real shot
I say hell yeah!
Your sisterhood is your bond
Do not let it break
You guys feeling out of place?
Like maybe they're judging you before you've had a chance to express yourselves?
You're in this position for 10 minutes
You gonna drown in a pool of white girl tears, or are you gonna cowgirl it up?
I'm from Kappa next door.
You shook our house.
We lost  a row of totally irreplaceable shot glasses.